Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
December 28th,
2050 the final
Monday
of 2015.
All right.
What are you going to?
Huh?
You gotta take advantage of it?
You're going to get out there and fucking head.
I just saw this really douchey commercial.
I'm recording this Sunday while I'm watching the end of the Seattle game and
watching the packers get their fucking asses kicked by cardinals.
Um,
I just saw this commercial,
right?
This,
this lady,
she's in her car,
right?
Cute as a button driving along and she's in this city and she's like,
there's over 2 million for his 60,317 people in this city and only one me.
And then she goes,
I like those odds.
And then this chick starts singing
fucking fight or whatever.
The fuck.
So stupid.
I never seen hype over.
Absolutely nothing.
Like,
well,
what do you mean you like those odds?
There's a,
is there a way to improve those?
Odds are you're going to drive up on the sidewalk and try to lower the fucking
numbers.
Yeah.
I like those.
I don't feel like fucking taken out anybody today.
I guess I can live with that.
Ah,
is this like the result of like sports,
like athletes and rappers and stuff?
Shit.
Talking.
It's become such a part of the culture that you got to say something dumb like
that.
Like back in the day you'd moved to the city and you'd be like,
oh Jesus Christ,
look,
go to these people.
I mean I pulled away,
I put my head down and I gave it the old college try and hopefully things work
out for me and I could get my own little piece of the pie here right now.
Yes.
Fucking 3 million people here and just me.
Yeah.
Yes.
Suck my Dick.
I can handle that.
I can drive into the street and your Ford focus the fuck are you talking about?
What are you getting the trunk of your car that gives you that much confidence?
Huh?
Where do you go?
You got some gold bars,
Huh?
Um,
anyways,
I'm watching the end of the Seattle game here cause I feel like the Seahawks are
going to come back.
You know,
all sneaky Pete,
everybody's fucking talking about this guy.
They're talking about that guy.
Slowly but surely Seattle is clawing their way back into it.
Um,
hopefully there'll be on the road so we don't have to listen to how loud they
are.
Again,
low here in Seattle.
It's such a loud stadium.
We're gonna allow there.
You're just worried about Seattle.
You don't see one lumberjack in the fucking crowd,
you know,
with all the logging that goes on up there.
It's a bunch of coffee drinking cunts,
wearing a little curt with the Kurt Cobain fucking goatee.
Um,
you'd think every once in a while you'd find somebody actually wearing a flannel
because there were a lumberjack.
Not because they're into pearl jam.
That's all I'm saying.
It was Eddie did.
Eddie vetter,
did he use to cut down trees?
How about Kurt Cobain?
Did they use to do that stuff?
Is that what they did?
Is that why they dress like that or where they mocking with a dressing like
lumberjacks in an ironic way.
Um,
and if foreshadowing of the hipster movement that took hold somewhere in the mid
two thousands,
or maybe they were just cold,
you know,
it's always raining out there and they have to sing.
Maybe they wanted to protect their instrument.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
I saw,
I got jogging down the street today in jeans and like these sneakers that were
mocking,
running sneakers and then he had a tee shirt on in this weird sort of tank top
and the exact same haircut of people I used to see have in like 1975.
You know,
it was just like this.
You try and really fucking hard.
I don't,
I don't understand it.
I don't understand.
Just your whole fucking wardrobe and you'll look is mocking another decade.
Is that what it is?
I don't fucking,
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't pretend to know.
Anyways,
let's talk a little sports here.
As much as people can't fucking stand,
a lot of people can't stand.
I don't give a shit,
you know,
I don't give a shit.
I don't have any advertising this week.
Okay.
That's what it's come down to.
You know,
me being a smart Alec in all of these fucking ads.
Right?
And then you guys egg and beyond.
Oh yeah.
You guys egging me on.
You know,
I,
I can't walk away from a fucking easy laugh.
Um,
now look at me,
Amanda in the year empty handed,
60 minutes of podcasting and no advertising
and only just one.
Me.
I like those odds.
Fucking toe shoes.
Good Lord.
I'd rather eat glass and fucking have to watch that whole fucking Yolo.
You know how we do a daily,
everything is so fucking important.
Me and my brothers,
um,
Oh don,
I just sound like an angry old man.
I'm not actually,
I'm actually got my feet up.
I'm drinking a Miller.
I'm having a good time.
Is a snow globe within reach?
I mean,
I don't have a lot to complain about.
Um,
you know,
and we're all extinct.
I think that's going to be the big thing that aliens,
we'll look at one day,
you know,
but they'll find,
they'll unearth is snow globes and they'll try to figure out what the fuck they
meant.
You know,
they probably think it was some sort of power source.
They hovered their hands over it.
Entity somehow could.
Anyway,
so let's talk about the,
let's talk about a little bit of football.
So,
mmm.
I got,
you know,
word,
I don't even know how the fuck I found out about it.
That Peyton manning was accused
by all people,
Al Jazeera and God knows,
if you want to know about the national football league,
I don't know about you guys,
but I go to Al jazeera.com,
you know.
Okay.
I sift through all the Mohamad stories and the fuck it,
uh,
what the u s government's really doing it.
I get to their,
their sports page.
Okay.
And I uh,
yeah,
then I try to see what's going on in,
in NFL football.
So
according to this,
this Al Jazeera,
you know,
Al Jazeera USA,
all right.
The off shoe,
you know what kind of like those Suny fucking colleges,
w Sony,
Dell High,
Suny Syracuse,
what are the,
and all those fucking get off those colleges that have like more,
more change than like Mcdonald's.
Yeah,
right.
You know what I'm talking about?
So anyway,
so they did some sort of a,
the u s version,
um,
did some sort of investigative reporting and a allegedly found out that,
uh,
you know,
Peyton manning and among others had been using HGH and Blahblahblahblahblah now
do I believe in,
I don't give up.
I don't even give a shit personally.
But what was bugging me was the unbelievable lack of coverage.
You know,
it's a patriots fan watching my team get accused of every fucking thing under
the sun and every fucking accusation being taken as the absolute fucking truth,
right?
Right.
Through fucking baseball season.
You know,
other owners hiring people to investigate us.
And guess what?
The fucking study that the losing fucking owner paid for came up with,
right.
Not a fucking word,
not a fucking word about it.
Fucking hilarious.
They're saying that Peyton's wife is a pharmacist.
I mean,
there's enough circumstantial evidence here to get Tom Brady fucking a six game
suspension.
It ain't gonna happen.
You know,
why?
Cause it's not the patriots,
it's not the Patriots.
And also it's Al Jazeera.
So I think,
uh,
at some point,
the whole support the troops,
you know?
MMM.
Where we're trying to give them freedom.
Somehow that kicks in I think to it.
But uh,
you know,
I just look at,
okay.
Personally I don't think he did it all right.
However,
if he did,
I don't give a shit and I don't know.
No,
it doesn't change any of his fucking numbers.
To me.
The guy was on the ropes,
you know,
his fucking neck was dislocated from the rest of his body.
You,
we could spin it around like an hour.
I mean,
you can't play football like that.
So he goes overseas or whatever the fuck he did.
Right.
He goes over to the Colby Center,
they stick his fucking liver in a center.
Fuge whatever the fuck it is that they do over there,
you know,
they spend your blood around the thing and they stick it back in.
Yeah.
And then you're like a vampire.
You just set up in the coffin and next thing you know you're taking someone to
the rack.
I don't have a problem with dad.
I love that athletes do that shit.
I'm not saying Peyton did,
obviously,
I don't think he did.
Ah,
cheeses.
And now the fucking card and it's got a God damn safety.
If they don't take this away,
they're going to take this away.
Okay.
We got a penalty all the day.
Facts personal fast tackling the quarterback too hard.
He got it boss full.
That's illegal.
You can't touch him in the head.
You can't touch him in the April.
Be careful around his waist.
If you could just sort of pick them up and lay him down like a toddler that fell
asleep on your cell phone and you're just going to talk a man.
We won't have to throw all these damn flax.
Um,
anyways.
I don't think he did the ship,
but if he did,
I'd be excited.
I'd be happy that he did it.
You know why?
Because eventually,
whatever,
whatever those fucking doctors learned,
allegedly what it shooting that shit into fucking GRANDPA's neck there.
Eventually that's going to help me out someday when I'm old or it's funny,
I'm older than him,
but his body,
his body is like fucking,
you know,
20 years older than me.
Right.
Although he does have a nice head of hair.
I'm just saying everything that these athletes have taken,
especially the illegal shit,
that's all going to help us in the future.
Who knows?
Maybe something that they're trying to take to get that ball and socket joint
back into place.
So suddenly find that the,
that a side effect is it grows a nice lion's mane worth the hair.
Right.
And then while I'm going to be lining right up for,
that's what happened with Viagara,
they would,
they would go out,
I can't remember what the fuck it was supposed to do.
It was supposed to do something else.
Then all of a sudden the guy's like,
yeah,
you know why?
Yeah,
my left hand's still twitching,
but God damn it,
my Dick is standing up.
And then they would probably be sitting in the boat while I stop thinking about
sexual things.
We'll try to do an experiment here.
And he's like,
no,
you don't understand.
I'm not thinking about anything and my deck is not stood up in years.
And then they all went,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
And they told the guy to just sit down.
Right.
And then all the scientists got together and they would just go like,
wait a second,
wait a second.
We just,
it didn't fix fix his lefthand twitching,
but it made his dick stand up.
Now I just hear me out.
Um,
this might be a little gross,
but I have this sneaking suspicion that a lot of guys over the age of 70
okay.
That if they still could would whip their dick out and fuck something.
Yeah.
But I think that this is a very large untapped market of old guys with flacid
Cox that we could bring back to life.
Get them back out there,
you know?
Okay.
Fucking some prostitutes and get them into that.
They've been thinking clear for the first time in their life since they hit
puberty.
Let's,
let's,
let's get them back into trouble again.
What do you say?
I want to see an 80 year old get a sexual harassment case,
don't you?
And actually,
you know you've got the blue pills,
so who knows?
All I'm saying is all you fucking Patriot cuts out there.
Haters out there.
All right.
Been in the Patriots up and down.
Lie in your asses off.
So they stole playbooks and they filled the last practice and all those lies
that were told that were presented as truth until ESPN detracted them at 1230 in
the fucking morning.
Bunch of fucking cowards.
Right?
I want you guys to,
I want you to treat this circumstantial evidence on old,
long neck Magoo the same fucking way you did on the dimpled wonder there in New
England.
I want you guys to fucking talk about it.
Okay?
I want you to talk about how they've gotten away with murder.
I want you to trace it back to Jim or say,
and I want to see this be a big fucking scandal that goes right through baseball
season,
right?
Can you guys do it?
Come on.
I think you got it in Ya.
Okay.
I made,
if you could take fucking air pressure for fucking eight months.
I know you can take HGH and his wife's a pharmacist.
Come on.
It's right there.
All the circumstantial evidence you need.
Yeah.
Where'd you read this now to Sarah.
That's game set.
Match at a buffalo wild wings.
Um,
okay.
Anyways,
I love it.
It's nice to see somebody else get falsely accused and they don't have a fucking
goddamn whatever the fuck is on the side of our helmet.
Got Damn it.
Those are ugly uniforms.
I've hated those things since day one.
Okay.
I don't understand why this quarterback is where Neil Lomax is.
Old Number or is he wearing number five?
I have no idea.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
the uh,
patriots lost to the jets.
We lost to the jets and a congratulations to the jet fans out there.
I know.
You're all excited.
You're like,
oh my God,
we fucking beat him.
A Windsor where and I know that they're really injured and stuff and I know,
but Blahblahblahblahblah and Oh my God,
can you believe that that guy fucked up the coin toss.
He won the coin toss and then he said he was going to kick off a blah,
blah,
blah.
And this is how dumb jet fans are.
They actually think that that wasn't a calculated move by the genius bill
Bellacheck.
Everybody thinks that's a big fuck up.
Maybe one thinks that guy's going to get yelled at by bill Bellacheck.
You ever think that maybe bill told him to go and do that?
Say go out there.
All right.
Is the deal.
If they win the coin toss,
they're going to get the ball.
All right?
If we win the coin toss,
you just tell him you gonna kick it.
All right,
because here's the deal.
We're really injured right now.
All right?
Okay.
W We,
we,
we got nobody left for a fucking division two team here at this point.
All right?
I don't know about you guys,
but I would love to play the jets in the playoffs.
We all know we can kick their fucking ass,
but the problem is it's those green cards might not make the playoffs.
Okay?
Now we've made it look good here.
We've tied them to the regular season.
Let's,
uh,
you know,
let's just make sure they win this one.
Maybe they'll law,
maybe they'll fucking,
when a nice tackle by the quarterback on a fumble.
Very nice.
Um,
maybe they'll low,
you know,
they be,
we'll get to meet him again in the playoffs.
Then will be healthy and then we'll kick their fucking ass.
There'll be one less thing we got to worry about.
And I know people in New York City,
a big thing in New York season,
a city is a regular season winner for 90% of your fucking tapes.
Not for the GI.
It's not for the Yankees,
but for the rest of them it's a big fucking deal.
Okay.
It's a big deal.
If the next one,
a regular season game,
it's a big deal.
If the Brooklyn Nets,
oh,
the New York mets or the New York jets,
the New York Rangers and New York Islanders,
the buffalo bills,
the fucking sabers,
any of those other nine ass fucking teams.
If they went anything,
it's a big deal.
So congratulations.
Um,
I'm fucking with you,
man.
We totally screwed up,
but a,
and that could actually be a good thing for us.
You know,
I'd love to play the fucking jets again.
I liked the odds of us playing the jets again,
having lost to them the previous time.
That's one less week I got to worry about having said that,
I think,
uh,
I think it's,
this is,
this is not in depth analysis whatsoever,
but you got to admit Seattle,
uh,
Carolina or fucking Phoenix,
Phoenix looks like fucking world beaters.
Um,
I just don't think the AFC has it.
I don't think I always say that every fucking year.
We won it last year,
you know?
But who knows.
I don't,
I don't think we do all right enough with that shit.
Oh,
by the way,
you know,
it's so,
you know something.
I don't want to hear about it.
I don't want to hear about the fucking 72 dolphins drinking their fucking
champagne again.
You know,
I'd love to see a picture of that.
All those five foot nine defensive Lineman,
that's stupid ass tape.
I was so sick.
I hear it about those fucking guys,
you know enough already with the celebrating you had they,
those constant and have to deal with any sort of pressure.
What's compared to nowadays going undefeated.
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't even think the panthers really going to deal with anything,
you know?
No one gave a fuck.
It's Carolina don't get it only matters if it's in Boston or New York.
It's the only place pressure matters.
There's no pressure anywhere else in the fuck everyday.
But he sells you fucking live and it's just apple pies sitting on a window sill,
you know,
tell you guys just soft
fucking with you.
Um,
I would lovely Tony Roma's reaction to that.
After all the fucking shit he's taken a Dallas,
it's bad enough.
You got to get yelled at by people who can't fucking even play the game at a
high school level.
You got to look at people who get botox shot to their face wearing a cowboy hat,
questioning your abilities under center.
I mean,
I just,
I just don't understand it.
It's gotta be brutal itself.
But anyways,
getting back to the 72 dolphins,
so it's fucking conscience.
Back in the day,
like I told you,
it's sports was the last five minutes of the local news.
That's it.
That was it.
There was no big fucking story.
You know,
young people watch sports back then were sports fence.
That was it.
Half the halftime show at the super bowl would be like some local college band
and then that I'd done that Tech Tech Tech Tech Day.
It'll be a regular fucking halftime.
They played the super bowl during the day was like light out on the,
on the fuck at east coast.
Okay.
They play it outside.
Sorry.
Um,
anyways,
I,
I really don't want to hear about that.
I'm just being honest.
I'm not trying to be a cunt.
I'm just saying,
by the way,
I'm watching this,
as I mentioned,
I'm watching this Arizona Green Bay game.
Is anybody else hearing that fucking lady?
Every time the packers have the balls screaming or that little kid every time
they,
every time there's a play.
You just his presence.
Wow.
Okay.
It's been driving me nuts.
Um,
all right,
20.
I'm just switched over.
23,
10 St Louis Silva,
Seattle.
Seattle's got the ball and they're driving.
Oh,
this is perfect it down by two scores.
Two touchdowns.
They're going to win 24,
23 there's three minutes left.
We'll see what happens.
We will see what happened.
You know,
it's funny,
you guys already know what happens.
Why am I saying this?
Like it's an amazing thing.
All right,
so here's something for you this weekend,
right?
I drove out to visit some family,
So Faye,
Emily,
and I'm
the fucking,
uh,
you know,
we leave at like 11 in the morning because my wife likes to sleep,
and one thing I've learned,
I want thank,
you know,
when I was a kid,
like I'm in my house.
If someone was sleeping and you had something to say to them,
you just started talking to them,
which was so fucking annoying.
And um,
okay.
I just fucking,
you know,
I just don't do that to people.
You know what I mean?
I've tried to correct a few of the fucked up things that happened to me.
Um,
so my wife sleep and I'm just sitting there going,
oh my God,
this trappers can be horrific.
Which it was,
of course it was absolutely horrific.
And um,
okay,
we ended up,
we get on the highway,
I would drive and one drive and drive and it's just this fucking ridiculous
traffic.
And then my wife,
of course,
it has to be all right.
Which is one of the things that happens when you travel with a woman.
Okay?
They're going to be putting makeup on the car.
They're going to make your fucking an hour late at least.
And at some point they're going to have to pee.
So she's trying to hold it and she find just cause I can't hold it,
I got to go.
So I pull off the first fucking exit and the first fucking exit I pull into,
um,
it was like a circle k in a McDonald's.
And so I go for the Mcdonald's.
And uh,
it turns out that Mcdonald's is part of this fucking,
uh,
one of the what equals an outlet mall.
And this is the day after Christmas.
And,
uh,
I would think the day after Christmas,
there'd be nobody at a fucking mall.
Right.
You got all your gifts.
It's fucking over.
Right.
Stay home.
Enjoy the day off,
dude.
I get the,
it's fucking mopped.
You can't even get in.
Yeah.
Like my wife had to get out in traffic because she couldn't hold him or to run
into the fucking Mcdonald's.
And then I'm stuck in this traffic jam of fucking animals.
Yeah.
Bunch of fucking animals.
They're all walking.
First of all,
they're not walking on the sidewalk.
They're walking out where the cars are driving,
looking for parking spots,
and of course they're walking three,
four abreast.
Okay.
I swear to God with the population problem,
shouldn't you at least be able to just clip the last one?
Just fucking run him over a bunch of fucking animals just walking around,
coming out with more bags of shit.
It's like,
did she just get a bunch of shit?
So,
um,
of course my wife goes in there,
you know she's going to use the ladies room and there's always a fucking line.
I don't know what they do in there.
Okay.
But you know,
whatever,
whatever a guy does,
if a woman's doing it,
you got to add like another 60% yeah.
Time.
All right.
It takes you a minute.
It's going to take her a minute and 40.
Right.
You get involved with something that's going to take you 10 minutes.
You know what?
See it.
You see what happens?
It's going to take them 16 minutes and so on,
and that's on a good fucking day.
It's on a good fucking day.
So she goes in there.
You of course,
it's like fucking 9 million.
Let all that so fumble.
That's a fumble,
right?
Dad's knee wasn't on the ground.
The ball k bad right there,
right?
It's a fumble game over the ranch.
Are they going to beat him twice in one season?
Same Old Rams.
What do we got here?
They go into the video booth.
Be Carol is upset.
The rams are doing little dances like Dave.
Dave done something in the last fucking 15 years.
What are they so excited about?
Oh,
they got the ball.
I was just going to say,
how the fuck is it raining in the,
in a,
in Saint Louis.
They got a dome.
Then I realize the home team's cause I,
I'll never get used to that.
The home team not wearing white.
Ah,
that's funny.
This guy,
this guy's yelling at somebody in the crowd.
I don't care.
I don't give a fuck,
man.
I don't give a fuck.
You know what he's saying?
Yeah.
We want a Superbowl.
You never won shit.
I don't give a fuck.
Yes you do.
Um,
that's hilarious.
Oh,
the rams.
Why are they all the rams are being idiots right now.
They're fucking,
they're talking trash to the Saint Louis fans.
How does that help you?
How does that help you give them something to rally around?
Okay.
This is hilarious.
Seattle fans are getting the treatment they exist,
they fucking deserve,
and they,
I,
you know,
I guarantee they're going to get fucking offenders.
Um,
oh my God.
Well,
at least there are a bunch of lumber jacks and the crowds,
so they should,
you know what?
Now that it's raining and they're losing,
like all the fucking tech geeks are going to go leave and go to a coffee shop,
take out their mittens.
You know,
those fragile women too,
that like drink coffee,
they got to hold it with both hands because they're,
they're fucking,
they're,
their appendages are always fucking cold.
Does that we call your fingers,
Phalanges tarsals metal tarsals Phalanges.
Carpals metacarpals Phalanges.
Isn't that what I learned to biology class way back in the day?
Uh,
for Christ sake,
quit running the fucking ball and try to get a first down your pussies lay up
for all the ball and this area that rarely,
why is it easier and another area.
All right,
don't let it go.
You know,
this is usually the time I would take a break.
I take a break and I would read a read a little bit of advertising.
I never thought I'd say this.
I actually miss it.
I actually miss reading out loud.
Well,
why don't I read about Peyton manning out loud?
A little bit of advertising this week.
Paint.
Manning said he is furious and disgusted at an Al Jazeera report.
The second it says Al Jazeera,
this thing just holds no fucking water
that identified the Denver Broncos quarterback.
You know,
what a fuck does Al Jazeera get off doing a fucking,
you know what I mean?
Everybody getting out of their wheelhouse.
It's like when I was on Jimmy Fallon,
I was talking about Mcdonald's.
They started making salad.
You don't make salads the fuck are you doing?
No one's going to Mcdonald's to get a salad.
Nobody goes to Al Jazeera to fucking learn about what's going on in the NFL.
Yeah,
he's fucking idiots.
Correct.
When am I be better homes and gardens and find out what's going on in fucking
hockey?
You know,
I'm sorry,
I should be a little more openminded.
Shouldn't I?
Right.
Being the Hollywood liberal cunt that I am or should night,
so my wife has a new vehicle and uh,
it's got all the latest technology on it and this thing,
it has like these sensors.
So if you get anywhere near anything,
like when you're first starting to get close to it just goes
boom,
boom.
Get up closer.
It goes,
but more,
more,
more.
And then when you're [inaudible] way of,
you're in danger of hitting,
somebody just goes,
so every time you back out of my fucked up driveway,
because there's no room and it's shaped like an upside down triangle.
Well,
the walls start closing in whenever I'm backing up the fucking thing,
it's gone,
baby,
do the health.
And I'm just in there,
just go on,
shut the fuck he
screaming like it literally,
I have to.
Same fucking anxiety I had when I back that thing up because of those stupid
fucking ringing things.
It's like when I was a kid and I used to watch those action movies and I used to
believe at some point that that Stallone or Schwarzenegger could actually die in
one of their own movies,
you know,
in the end when they would be like,
do I clip the red wire,
the white wire,
you know,
and it's counting down three,
two,
one.
Like that level of stress as I'm just backing out.
So what I've learned to do is I've learned to block it out.
Like now I just accept that that's what it's gonna do you know,
when I was actually thinking this must be like,
what field goal kickers do?
Well,
they don't see those fat meat tinted fucks behind the,
uh,
they just see the,
they just see the goalposts.
Right.
And I'm just going to put it right through there.
And they don't,
they don't see all those people flapping their arms and screaming and jumping up
and down and doing whatever the fuck it is that they feel like they should be
doing.
You know?
Or like when you go to take a foul shot,
it's the same thing.
Like that's the mental space.
I feel like I have to go into just a back,
a fucking care van or whatever the fuck we got here.
I did not fuck you call it style of vehicle out of the goddamn driveway.
MMM.
Anyways,
can you tell him filibuster in here.
You know,
I'm just trying to get to a half an hour then I'm going to do the fucking,
uh,
I'm going to do the reeds for that.
We all,
by the way,
thank you for everybody for rap and who've been watching.
F is for family.
Uh,
I just,
I got word from somebody who knows one of the guys at the top of a Netflix food
chain there and they said that F is for family,
is killing it.
So I want to thank you guys for that.
And uh,
we're already starting to think about,
you know,
what we can do in season two to take it to a new level.
Um,
you know,
provided they fucking,
give us one.
We'll see.
Oh,
who's that?
Which Barbara is that?
Is that Tiki or Rod Day?
I don't know.
Oh,
but you know what?
The Guy,
the guy won Fox.
That's the guy used to be on ESPN long time ago and all of a sudden he was just
gone.
He was,
God,
you know that he was one of the guys,
I got the idea for that pilot I did with the always sunny guys that for some
reason they didn't fucking pick up
one of those guys that was just there and then they're just gone.
You're like,
what the fuck ever happened to that guy?
Whatever happened to hang on a second.
I gotta I gotta turn the light on.
It's getting dark here.
Hey,
here's something positive you guys can think you can think about here.
Is that as of what the 22nd or the 21st or whatever the days are now getting
lighter.
Al fucking lighter.
Um,
how do you know if you're broke it tone?
I don't know what the fuck is wrong with my toe.
Every time I've branded a little bit,
I get a shot of pain.
I can't tell if it's just cause I'm fucking old.
I just have old feet.
Now
speaking of old feet,
I was in cvs,
you know,
they got the foot aisle.
I was trying to find these Ziploc bags cause uh,
I'm going to make a bunch of those round fucking ice cubes.
I'm sticking them in a Ziploc bag and stuffing them in the cooler for the Rose
Bowl.
So when we drink scotch at like seven in the morning,
had a glass,
as you know,
we can have a little round ice cubes.
You know what I mean?
It's all about the fucking tail gate,
right?
So this is all I'm thinking about.
So I'm going into cvs.
I went to the gym this morning and it wasn't open so early.
I got there,
but the cvs was open.
So I was like,
I know I'm going to go in there and I'm going to get some zip lock bags and I
come walking in there and there's two employees.
One of them is fucking vacuuming,
the other one's stuck in the God damn shelves.
Okay.
So,
and all I see is a bunch of self checkout things and people checking themselves
out and I'm like,
I'm not fucking doing this.
So I just walk up to the register,
I'm standing there,
I'm standing there and then the lady comes by with the vacuum cleaner and the
fucking store is open.
She goes,
oh,
it's just,
just a self helps are open now.
And I just said,
well I don't do that.
I just left the shit,
walked out,
what it should have been.
It's like,
I don't do that stuff.
I need someone to help me at this register right now.
And they're just like,
well I can't help you because if I get,
you know,
there's no customer service anymore.
And when I was,
I left and I just sat there thinking about it going like,
you know what?
That's going to be the future
and the future,
there's going to be,
nobody works.
So you just gonna walk in like at night when there's nobody there,
they're going to stock the shelves and then they're just gonna fucking leave.
And then during the day,
you know,
you walk in and then you,
what you have to do is you pick out whatever's there and then you scan it,
you bag it yourself,
and then you leave.
And if you go and try and steal anything,
there's going to be one of those big Robo cop look at things in the corner and
it will fucking blow your brains out.
And it will be justified because human life won't mean shit at that point
because it's not going to be enough food or water left.
So you know,
and no one's going to feel bad that you're dead.
Even your own family at that point,
they're like,
good,
well one less fucking grumbling stomach in the house.
Right.
That's what I got out of that experience.
So then anyways,
I go up to the fucking gym,
you know,
kills me.
There's a person at my gym and they have a pit bull and they,
they tie it up to the rail and they go in and they work out.
And every time I come walking out and I look at that pit bull,
it looks so fucking sad.
It's ECO walking.
I was just looking at you like,
are you my owner?
Because I'm not enjoyed sitting hair feels so fucking bad for the thick.
It's unbelievable.
That contempt.
I have few humanity.
You just give me one fucking,
I love dogs.
They're the fucking,
I don't even mind cats and that costs,
you know what I mean?
But then I polluting rivers,
right?
Cats don't make me fucking scan my own shit and bag it.
Do they,
although they do shit in the house,
but you know that when you get them,
that's a great play right there.
You know something,
the guy,
you know the uh,
oh,
I was calling Russell Peters,
the rustle a Rabinow which said what the fuck's a quarterback first?
I Dunno any but Russell Wilson,
right.
Thank God he turned around so I can read it on his back and he fucking over
through somebody and back in the day the guy was jumping up,
you know back in the day safety would come over and just fucking give the guy a
nice fucking head shot and he pulled up.
He did hit him that that is a good tech.
That is a good thing.
It hasn't been done for good reason.
I mean they just did it because why?
They don't want to get fucking sued,
you know?
You know I heard that will Smith concussion movie that a,
the NFL made him take a lot of shit out of it.
You probably like,
what the fuck does NFL have to do with Hollywood?
Well,
if you follow the family fucking tree of the corporations,
I think it somehow ESPN is owned by ABC and they owned some movie fucking thing
and the NFL is on ESPN.
They go,
Hey,
can you take out all the shit that implicates us for looking the other way?
It just Disney fire just a little bit.
Could you do that force or also go to another network and they were like,
yeah,
sure,
absolutely,
absolutely touched dad.
Seattle.
See that now?
That right there,
it should scare people as much as those rams fans are fucking wave in at the
Seattle fence.
You know we're going to go hold a fucking candle light village village for a
village.
Oh No.
What is the word?
A candle light.
It's not village.
Do you know how many times I fucking heard that in my life and I've never said
it out loud and I don't know how to say it.
Does this mean I'm dumber?
It's just like happen to people.
Okay.
Candlelight.
You know this is what I do now when I don't know something I'm going to write
typing
had I wrote hand head a vigil is what it is,
right?
Fillage candle
light and it's coming up.
Dinner
vigil.
The fuck is a vigil.
It sounds like the name of a fucking old guy.
Vigil.
Get it here.
A vigil,
a period of keeping awake during the time usually spent asleep,
especially to keep watch a prey.
That's hilarious.
Anytime you light candles at night,
people call it a vigil.
It's like,
dude,
well what?
When's your bedtime without right then it's not a virtual yet.
You gotta you gotta fucking be here.
One in the morning,
two in the morning.
All depends on what you're dealt.
You do coke.
Would you do coke tonight?
All right,
well you got to be holding that candle still at seven in the morning.
Um,
all right.
What are we doing here?
What are we doing here,
bill?
We're fucking looking up words cause you were a dope.
All right,
well you know that happens.
It happens.
Fucking relax.
All Right,
Time Dad.
37 minutes and weekends.
We can read a few here.
We can read a few.
Jesus,
how fucking fucked up is that Terry Bradshaw's shingles commercial.
He just barged into people's houses and start showing them pictures of open
source.
I have no idea what shingles is,
but he said,
do you eat chicken?
And the person was like,
yeah,
he goes set out.
They always scare the fuck out of you.
But then you look at Terry,
he doesn't have any open source.
So you know,
he didn't get vaccinated,
so I think he's just complaining that it hurt a lot.
Shit.
And I gotta look up shingles and you know they're going to take me to the roof
shingles.
Shingles say,
oh my God.
You know,
to only white people get shingles or do they only care about white people
getting shingles?
It's one or the other because all of the show in some just drawn white guy where
it looks like somebody just an alien clawed his rib cage shingles,
herpes zoster.
Oh Jesus.
The fuck part of the Internet.
Am I on?
You know,
it's fucked up when when the first like 10 are all medical before you even get
to Wiki.
Wiki is usually the first thing.
Like with vigil,
they don't give a fuck.
Right.
All right,
you got to go to Wikipedia.
Take it to my level.
Shingles also known as Zoster,
herpes zoster or Zoster,
I don't know.
Or Zona is a viral disease characterized by a painful skin rash.
I'll toughen the fuck up.
Put some talcum powder on it with blisters involving a limited area.
Typically the rash occurs on either the left or the right of the body or face in
a single stripe two to four days before the rash occurs.
They may be pain or tingling in the area.
Otherwise,
there are typically few symptoms.
The rash usually heals within two to four weeks.
However,
some people develop ongoing nerve pain,
which may last for months or years.
A condition called posts therapy,
hectic,
neurologic,
Ludia.
In those with poor immune function,
the rash may occur widely if the ration falls,
The eye vision loss may occur.
Well,
I got to tell you nothing and that told me to get a vaccine on roll the dice
gives a shit.
It's a great excuse to take three,
four weeks off of your life.
I'd love to come in,
but I got shingles and then you know,
they clear up in two weeks and two weeks later you're like,
Nah,
I still got them.
Think I should be good next week.
He'd just take a month off of the fuck would want to do that.
You get to act like a homeless person,
but you're inside,
which I think is probably the best kind of homelessness.
Right.
I'm sorry.
All right,
let's get to some questions here for the week.
Um,
all right,
hang on,
hang on.
You know,
I never thought I'd like Miller Lincoln and they brought back this old school
bottle and I keep them nice and cold and I don't know.
I like a pilsner.
Alright,
psychosis.
Um,
oh wait a minute.
What the fuck am I doing?
This 17 seconds left.
Here comes an onside kick.
Seattle is down by six points.
Alcoa present.
It kicks the ball off and he kicked it out of bounds.
Ah,
Jesus,
the headsets coming off.
I love when that is any better.
When your coach takes the headset off,
it's fucking over.
It takes it off with a smile on his face,
I should say.
All right,
here we go.
Psychos.
Hey belt.
You get a lot of emails with very specific situation.
A situation,
situation
is ECC on the Sopranos.
All right.
I'm not going to lay out every detail of what I'm dealing with,
but I'd like to get some advice from you.
How do you deal with psychosis?
Do you ignore them?
Do you engage and confront them?
A very general question.
I know,
but let's say someone is talking shit and they're just a sociopath making shit
up.
I ignored it,
but now the problem is getting bigger.
I'm thinking about just blowing the whole thing up and confronting everyone
involved.
Again,
I know I'm not giving you all the details,
but the truth is it's just that simple and I don't want to bore your listeners
with dramatic details.
Well Dude,
the traumatic details is how I stretched the shit out for an hour.
Anyways,
he goes,
I should mention,
I do have to see the psychos occasionally,
so it's not like an out of sight out of mind thing.
Thanks,
love the new show.
Oh,
thank you.
Okay.
All right,
so you know,
you're not talking about psychos on the train.
Psychos on the train.
You just ignore.
You know what I mean?
Until you can't,
they're coming at you.
Then you got to do it.
The old front kick a little right there,
Fred.
You always got to go with your feet with fucking psychos.
Gotta go with your feet.
You don't want any open skin touching a psycho.
You don't know what they got.
They bite,
they scratch the fucking horrific you gave me.
All right there.
Fred,
right to the fucking chest.
Like that guy who fucking kick the guy in his leg broke.
He used to come into the the,
the octagon with like a fucking like a spider.
The fuck was his name.
He's one of the legends of all time there.
I'm not disrespecting and right now I just don't watch enough of that UFC stuff.
All I know is if I could steal any move for mixed martial arts,
it would be his front kick.
We're a guy knows you.
He's in a fight with you.
A professional fighter knows he's in a fight with you and yes,
front kick is so God damn sly.
It comes right up and underneath,
right between both his arms,
right under the person's job,
right day a Fred,
you're then you're on your back.
It's fucking over.
MMM.
Anyways.
Uh,
how do you deal with psychos?
All right.
I you saying women are,
these men do ignore them.
Do you engage,
confront that very general question.
I know,
but let's say someone is talking shit and they just,
they're just a sociopath making shit up.
I,
I'm always a fan of walking away.
If you could just walk up there,
just psychos,
just fucking walk away.
But you got to see him every day.
MMM.
You know what dude,
you need to write back in next week.
Okay.
And give me more details cause I got to see like what is your relationship to
them?
Okay.
You know,
or is what they're saying.
So embarrassing.
You don't want to tell me.
You don't need to tell me what the fuck they're saying or doing.
Um,
you said I do have to see the psychos occasionally.
He got to see him occasionally.
Yeah.
I,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't.
Okay.
I Dunno.
I don't,
I don't know what to tell you,
dude.
This is so fucking vague.
Yeah.
I have no idea.
I can tell you that if they're in your,
uh,
I dunno,
I'm a big,
you know,
cutting the head off the snake kind of thing.
And that doesn't mean you got to fucking confront somebody.
I mean,
you just cut him out of your life.
It's just done.
You know what I mean?
And sometimes that involves a conversation.
Sometimes it just evolves.
Just,
just creating a new life somewhere else.
Go to a different bar,
get an east sound young,
get another fucking job,
whatever the fuck it is,
just leave,
get on with your fucking life.
Gives a fuck.
Life's too short.
You know what I mean?
But you don't need to be getting involved in,
you know,
screaming and yelling and that reality show stuff and oh no,
you didn't bitch.
And then he fucking slap each other.
Whatever the fuck happens nowadays.
Um,
I wouldn't,
uh,
I wouldn't be involved in it.
Okay.
It,
I mean,
I'm just,
I don't know what the fuck to tell you though,
do you didn't get me off information.
I'm sorry.
I feel like I'm failing you here.
Uh,
so right in again next week and I'll do my best.
All right.
Okay.
No presence.
So JJH dear bill,
love your work.
I know you will judge me and hate me,
but hear me out.
Uh,
I been with my boyfriend for more than a year.
We're,
we're both young.
Uh,
women.
There's such geniuses.
You know what I mean?
Like she already has me going like,
no,
I won't judge you all.
I mean,
hurry the fuck you going to say,
you know,
did their brilliant.
She just fucking write down that star Trek Shit that where they put the worm and
the guys how much she used.
She's already,
she's in my brain.
All right.
We are both young but from completely different backgrounds.
I am a European from a middle class family while his family is loaded and their
culture is generally very generous.
Don't get me wrong.
I make my own living and can afford anything I want.
We love each other crazily,
I travel all the time and get them presence on a weekly basis.
Perfumes,
perfumes.
All right,
I'm going to say that's a language barrier thing.
Colognes,
you mean shoes,
clothes,
you name it.
Uh,
I love making my loved ones happy and never expect anything.
I pulled my wallet out for every single dinner and we always pay half if we stay
in a hotel or travel.
How you're all aces so far.
Why am I going to judge you or hate you?
Gee,
what's going to happen in the second half here?
Um,
lightly,
lightly.
Uh,
it was our anniversary.
I got him a nice present,
but he didn't get,
he didn't even give me a flower.
Said,
I'm so sorry.
I'll make it up tomorrow.
Uh,
she goes on the kind of person who always says,
no,
come on.
I don't need anything.
Uh,
for Christmas,
I invited his family and friends,
cooked an amazing dinner at,
gave every single one of them presence.
Didn't get a thing
from him too.
I live far away from where I'm from and he's the only one I have.
So I felt like a kid who had been bad the whole year and woke up the next day to
a Christmas tree was called,
oh,
he didn't even get you anything.
I tried my best to stay positive.
At the end of the day I can go and get myself any stupid stuff I want.
It's really not about things.
I've never felt so bad about myself and I'm really,
am I really so shallow to cry about a stupid President present?
But I promise,
but I promise it would make me so happy to know that he found the time to pass
by a shop and get me a lip gloss or whatever.
All right.
Um,
no.
Who doesn't appreciate Nice stuff?
I constantly give gifts to family members.
We were all in a great location.
Okay.
You've said this a zillion times.
I would love to hear your opinion about it.
I know this makes me sound like a materialistic can not,
if you went,
you made a dinner and bought them all this other stuff that Jesus Christ,
but I wanted to keep the email minimal.
You didn't keep it minimal.
And I like how you keep going.
The,
Hey,
I'm just,
you know,
this might be your problem.
I know you're going to hate me,
but I know I don't know what you're doing here.
I don't want you to think I'm blah,
blah,
blah.
You almost see you.
I think you need a little more self esteem unless this is your own way of,
uh,
get me to say what you want.
Anyways,
he said,
he saw me sat and asked what was wrong and I couldn't hold it anymore.
I said,
it was Christmas time and it did not get a single gift from anyone in this
world.
Uh,
try not to sound like I'm blaming him.
I said,
my parents or brothers or whatever,
he said,
I should be grateful for what I have.
It's Cetera.
I cried and apologized and said how bad I've made them feel.
But you got him something too.
But I have a feeling nothing will change.
When I was little,
I would save for months to get my family something he never experienced anything
like that.
He has everything you could possibly imagine,
I guess presence,
our norm,
receiving them,
not giving them,
oh,
I don't know.
I really wished to get the answers.
Am I dumb shell a person.
I don't want to stop giving him presence for the essential occasions,
even if he never gives me a thin thank you for everything.
Happy New Year.
If this email is even remotely true,
that guy's a fucking sociopath and you can do way better.
I don't give a fuck how much money as if that's remotely true.
Okay.
I find it hard to believe that his family came over.
You cooked him a dinner,
you got all of them gifts and they didn't get you anything.
Okay.
Um,
if that is true and he's rich and you're from a lower class,
I'm starting to thank the family doesn't think you're good enough for them.
They wanted to make a statement and maybe they don't even need to.
The fact that he didn't get you anything.
Maybe he's just banging you
Barlow.
It's kind of weird.
Yeah.
To spend a,
okay.
The holidays with some checky just bagging.
I don't know.
If something's a,
something's not right,
then you're not happy.
You're not getting what you want and he doesn't see,
you know,
he seemed like he was a cunt about it.
So I would say,
uh,
2016 move on to something else.
Okay.
That's what I would say.
You know,
unless he really just has fuck you money and then you got to do what he's going
to do eventually is have a mistress on the side,
a monstrous,
you know,
yeah.
Start fucking the God.
No,
uh,
yeah.
We'll get rid of the guy.
If what you're saying is even remotely,
it's such a one sided fucking story.
I find it hard to believe that anybody could be that fucking cold are oblivious
and that's coming from me who's was a fucking dope.
But if that is even remotely true,
yeah,
I would just get out of the relationship.
It's great.
You're not married,
you don't have any kids.
It's simple.
It's a conversation,
you know,
nowadays it could be a text message dear so and so and not feeling it.
Take it easy.
Send
and you change your number or just,
yeah,
it's,
it's
all right.
Local sports.
Talk a dear Billy Cosell.
I'm listening to some old podcasts and hearing you justifiably bitch about
sports talk radio in sports commentating,
uh,
has uh,
has become really comforting.
I thought maybe I was becoming a miserable grump in his thirties,
but I'm not,
I live in Houston and like any other city with a sports presence.
I'm tired of all of all of what I call sports drama.
I'm a little younger than you,
but I remember the days when the game was all was all people talked about the
actual game,
not just the pointless what ifs,
the consume every program and conversation next time you,
are any of your listeners listen to any of that,
follow up each comment with these questions.
Did they say anything?
Does this provide any insight beyond that of some jackass at a bar?
Is this what my grandfather fought for during the Big One?
I'm not completely pessimistic though.
I think there are some great analysis analysis out there and people who stay
focused.
I try and only listen to people who aren't trying to create a name for
themselves through loud mouth comments and wild claims just to gain attention.
I still like listen to people talk about sports in some respect,
a rant inspired boy in some respect.
Rent inspired me to look for something else.
So I found a local podcast called Houston sports talk.
I think you've edited out some words there.
I read every word of that sentence and it made no sense to me,
but I think you're,
you're listening to a new podcast and Houston called Houston sports talk
anyways.
Plain and simple.
It's been a lifesaver.
Thanks for making me feel better about my position on this subject.
Love F is for family.
Oh,
thank you.
Yeah,
you gotta be uh,
you know,
as much as I make fun at Espn,
you got to have some empathy where they're trying to fill up 24 hours a day and
a lot of times there just simply isn't enough to do it,
which is probably one of the main reasons why the Tom Brady fucking thing went
right through baseball season.
Um,
there was just no other scandals going on.
Air quotes,
scandals.
Um,
so that's what they do.
I just,
I can't sit there and watch it.
Like right now the game is over and I'm watching some guy,
Dan Quinn,
uh,
you know,
giving out game balls and people clapping in all different states of dress link.
What,
why do I need to see this?
I don't give a shit.
I know the Falcons won.
I just want to see the highlights.
I want to see some guy in a jock strap.
I don't,
I don't need to see that.
You know,
I write down there was a huge win for the falcons.
A little it of the national football league,
but was it too little,
too late?
And we were,
so there's the couches Jessie on the chopping block.
What's next for,
for Matty ice.
Does he stay in a letter?
Is he going to re up or is he going to look for greener pasture?
Um,
all right.
Dating someone with zero ambition,
a Billy Dick Fingers.
I don't even know what the fuck that means,
but I like it.
I got to tell you,
I like it.
A Billy Dick Fingers.
I recently staff
listening to your podcasts and you've got me hooked.
Always loved to stand up.
And when I found out you have a podcast,
shit was like a gift from God.
Ah,
aren't you a sweetheart?
Um,
anyways.
Anyway,
I had been dating this lady for almost three years now.
Things are going well,
but I'm starting to get a little concerned about her.
She started hanging around some people who I feel are a bad influence to her.
They drink and she lets them drive her drunk.
Oh God,
that's not good.
And all they do is smoke pot and Dick around.
Now I like when my girl,
uh,
can get out of the house and go out,
have fun with the friends,
but it starting to influence a personality.
And whenever I tried to call her out,
she says bullshit.
Like,
okay mom,
or let me live my life.
I recently been getting my creative slash ambitious crunch on and then working
on big things,
turning my hobby of music into a profession.
I'm trying to come up successfully in life and found myself at a critical point
where I need to cut all the negative people out of my life.
Dude,
you got your fucking head screwed on straight.
Exactly.
You're doing shit,
she's not doing shit right.
This goes to the same way,
the other way around.
If you,
if you're a woman and you got your shit together and you're with somebody does
not have their shit together,
you should be looking at,
you know,
and you fired some warning shots and they're like,
okay mom,
whatever.
It's just like I dude,
alright,
go live that life.
But those fucking people will drag you down with them.
All right,
God damn anchor around your neck.
So anyways,
content,
I love this email so far.
Um,
right now her lack of ambition in need to sit around all day and smoke pot has
kind of soul crushing and disappointing.
I really love this girl,
but I'm afraid I'll lose her to the shithead friends and she'll become a
completely different person.
How do I try and help her get her shit together without seeming like a
controlling Douche?
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Well,
I would memorize your last three sentences and I would just say it to her in a
nice way.
Just say,
listen,
I'll paraphrase what you wrote.
I really love you,
but I'm afraid that I'm going to lose you.
And I had the shit had friends.
All right?
I can't do it.
When you listen,
you just set it down.
Just say,
listen,
I need to talk to you.
All right?
Put down the bond focus.
All right.
You know,
I love you,
but I gotta tell you,
I've been concerned with the people that she'd been hanging around with lately
and I'm really feeling like it's starting to some,
let me finish.
Let me finish.
You don't have to agree with me.
I feel like it's an influencing your behavior.
Before you hung out with these people,
you are doing x,
Y,
and z.
Now you just kind of sit around the house smoking pot all day in it's soul
crushing to me,
okay?
It doesn't motivate me and I love you and to see you sitting there doing nothing
with your life is killing me,
all right?
I need you to turn it around.
Okay?
And this is not a little thing.
This is a major crossroads.
I can't say that this just say,
I need you to turn.
I need you to do something about it and then this is the deal.
Either she does or she doesn't and if she doesn't,
you fucking walk cause I don't give a fuck how much you love this woman.
You're going to end up resenting resenting her and hating her because she's
going to take you down with her.
That's it.
That's the mom that some other year kids sitting around fucking,
you know,
smelling like Bong water,
watching Bravo TV all fucking day.
The he can't have,
you can't have it.
You can't have it.
It's it.
All right.
This is what you'd take her out back like fucking like Pauly Paul.
He talked to Henry Health about drugs.
Stay away from that shit.
I'm not saying slap her in the face after you say it.
You know,
just sit there as you're cooking something.
Stay away from that shit.
All right?
I don't want that shit in my life.
That's not going to happen to me.
All right.
I've got a friend of mine,
he's got a wife,
was a total fucking pothead.
Okay?
He's only making 30 grand a year.
That guy was on his way to being an executive,
right?
That ain't happened for me.
He's going to die in that cubicle if that didn't happen,
and to me,
don't you,
you.
You're doing exactly what you need to do here and you questioning the right
thing and I'm gonna tell you something,
you're going to be successful in life because not only did you recognize this
and the person that you're with,
despite the fact that you love him,
all right?
You motivated yourself and you understand already to get negative people out of
your life to it.
You got to fucking do it.
Okay?
This is,
this is a onetime conversation.
All right?
That's it.
Get your shit together.
You say it nicely.
All right.
If you don't see,
you don't see him turning around.
That's it.
Fuck that dude.
There's so many fucking great motivated people out there that you could be with,
okay?
You don't,
you don't need to shift the fucking [inaudible].
You were already a parent.
You don't even apparent yet.
You've got a big fucking babysit in there that's on drugs.
The worst kind of a baby and an adult.
One on drugs.
Oh,
he got me heated here.
Sorry.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Um,
I'll talk to you guys on a Thursday,
which I believe is New Year's.
Is that New Year's Day?
Wait a minute.
What's Today's date?
That's set it earlier,
right?
Monday the 28th,
29 30 31.
I'll do one.
I'll do one and maybe I'll have Paul Versey.
He's going to be in town because we're going to be at the,
uh,
the Orpheum in downtown La.
The two wonderful shows everybody,
um,
to end this amazing fucking year that I had every year just keeps getting
better.
And uh,
this year was no different.
I want to thank everybody who's been watching.
F is for family and tweeting about it and Facebook and doing all the social
media.
Uh,
oh wait a minute.
Look at this.
Manning under fire.
It's made the local El de la knows what a fucking travesty.
If anybody has never done roids.
It's Peyton manning.
He's had a dad body his entire fucking career.
Leave the guy alone.
Evie did a cycle.
Just to get back out there.
It's because he loved the game.
It gives a fuck.
Ah.
Anyways,
that's coming from a patriots fan too.
I love the Guy,
you know?
Fuck it.
You know,
I've given a lot of shit over the years,
but he was a rival.
What do you want from me?
All right.
Anyways,
that I want to thank everybody wants it again for a telling people about it,
for watching it,
for rewatching it.
Please keep spreading the word.
Um,
that's the best hope we have for getting a second season.
Netflix has a ton of content and a finite amount of money.
So,
uh,
just because we're doing well doesn't mean we're going to get a second season.
So please help spread the word and a,
and that is it.
That is it.
That is all I will talk to you on Thursday.
All right.
And I'll check it on you.
See you.